all for this ridiculous stupid
ugly flag about a total fad that I'm fed
up with and everyone else should be hey
guys I'm off the grid for August but
here's a generic intro to a clip we
wanted to show you there's a story
emerging from Portland the luniest left
cities known to Modern Man and it's been
reported that a woman suffering cancer
who questioned the need for a trans flag
at the clinic where she was receiving
treatment has been first bullied by
those meant to be treating her and asked
to submit to re-education and when she
refused she was told she can no longer
receive cancer treatment at Oregon
Health and Science University I mean you
can just feel the love and tolerance
there Douglas yeah
I mean you say it's Looney uh um region
you're quite right but I mean it doesn't
it doesn't really encapsulate the sheer
Madness of what has gone on in that City
and this isn't it just an example of it
I mean you you wonder where the adults
all went in a city like Portland that
was quite a proud City quite a
successful City in the past you wonder
where the adults all went what happened
to the what happened to The Men Who
would have stood up and said how dare
you treat this woman with cancer like
that how dare you what happened to the
men and women who would have chased such
an audacious
um brat as whoever it was who complained
about this woman
just chase them out of town what
happened to those people in in a society
at Portland I mean you can see you know
it's always all connected at the moment
the journalists and you know who uh is
is in a court in Portland and there's a
case being brought against
um some of the antifa activists who
hospitalized him with a brain hemorrhage
some time ago you know when I asked what
happened to the adults it's not at all a
rhetorical point the police in Portland
didn't bother to chase down the people
who hospitalized the journalist it was
left to the journalists to try to bring
a case himself you know we people really
need to to focus on how these places
have fallen apart but also to say have
you no self-esteem you people how could
you get your priorities so out of order
that that a woman with cancer is treated
like this or for this ridiculous stupid
ugly flag about a total fad that I'm fed
up with and everyone else should be hey
where are your priorities
what their moral compass appears to be
completely warped and it's the case with
Andy no there was so much footage of the
assault against him you would have think
it would have been the easiest thing to
identify some of those culprits and yet
the police seem to be uninterested in
the task